Last time,
oh,
I was arguing with you about some of the novel Tish,
the Dante introducers.
When the poem at the start,
we'll pull the Tori one.
Uh,
there are some full more,
uh,
for the,
we'll call this scriptive.
Um,
novelties,
light the time,
the question of time as a moral innovations.
The,
the focus on the connection,
the subtle connection between freedom and a new beginnings.
Uh,
the idea of freedom as first of all a political value,
um,
and the meeting with Cato,
uh,
so that,
though insisting on this novelties and that the novelty and the new or the
possibility of renewal is exactly,
uh,
at,
at stake in Dante's do politics.
I was also trying to emphasize,
and I think that that came through,
uh,
hopefully,
with,
with clarity,
the whole tension between the old and the new,
uh,
the,
the pool of the past,
the sense of nostalgia and whether it's an existential one or in the biblical
exodus story,
they don't style just for the,
the,
uh,
the time of a safety.
Our parents have the in of the Jews in Egypt,
even though within under the slavery or that Egypt stands forward.
So this is where some of the issues,
and then we moved down to Ken to tool where we,
we've specifically on the encounter of Dante with a musician by the name of
Casella where Dante dramatizes as a fan aware,
as if mindless of what of what had happened in the previous cancer and the
experience of the previous candle.
He just lapses into exactly the same time type of predicament that the previous
Canto had featured namely,
Ah,
here he is indulging in memories of the past,
uh,
lapsing into a form of idolatry,
self confrontational.
He's listening to the beauty and roar of the Canto of the,
of the,
of this song that has a will sing for him.
And then finally,
the presence of the eruption of Keto,
once again,
who focuses on the ethical,
uh,
domains of the place.
Purgatory is a place of moral purification.
And so,
uh,
he urges oldest holes that had gathered around the song of,
of,
uh,
Cassela to move away and the language that he uses that of dispersion,
like doves or pigeons like doves that,
uh,
go home dispersing throughout the,
the,
the plane.
Um,
clearly what,
uh,
in retrospect,
what is a parent?
I think in all of this,
this,
uh,
situations,
it's Dantes,
uh,
insistence home the power or the importance of a communal,
a communal desk.
They communal fate,
little this communal faith appears as defeated.
Let me just explain what I mean and then we move on with,
uh,
with,
today's readings.
In the case of Cato,
Cato has been defeated by the civil war between Pompei and sees to the point
that he had to commit suicide.
In the case of a castle,
a song that poem had managed to gather around the self,
nor only Dante,
but all the other souls who had become mindless of what we really were supposed
to do.
Continue.
They're climbing up the mountain and k intervenes.
And he also shatters that,
the,
as a losery,
that form of community.
What,
what,
what I think that Dante's after is the following,
they may have been defeat and,
and therefore the value of these experiments in communal communal existence,
that of Cato who commit suicide and that have the aesthetic gathering around the
poetry.
They are both partial and defeated and yet tech contain seeds that will be
necessary for his rethinking about how to renew a reconstruct a,
his idea of the common historical destiny.
This is really what,
uh,
and I hope it's,
it's fairly clear the bushes see this a little bit on,
uh,
today.
Um,
uh,
W I turn very briefly now to canto five for a couple of reasons because it's a
canto five.
If I had to give a general title to the cantor,
I would say,
uh,
that this deals with,
Dante sense of a retrospective knowledge.
I have been really focusing on a Dante turned to the future as you know,
uh,
Dan who,
who,
who thinks and reflects on hope,
who thinks and reflects about issues such as uh,
uh,
the,
the uh,
the future,
the future in general,
that this is freedom is and,
and time is the future is the real time.
Uh,
nothing else really matters.
Everything else can only be understood as part of even when it's passed with the
logical and the lying assumption that that which is past was once the future,
the only real,
the only reality of time.
So he understands improvisatory how time moves in a uni direction,
which is future oriented.
That so it's,
it's really a time as future that that turns out to be also returned to the
garden of Eden.
But that is kind of second thought,
uh,
for him.
He and now though in Canto five done timid souls that um,
the,
that sort of bring to the fore for him that power of retrospection this our
souls who managed to repent at the last minute.
It's almost as if,
again,
it's time,
it's a question of time,
but a time that is all to of inexhaustible.
It's always possible to full back,
reflect and turn one's life around.
One figure that he meets,
and this is Ken to five around line 90 years.
You should see in a moment why I select him.
Uh,
he meets a figure,
uh,
who is,
he,
he would identify himself,
uh,
bunk conte,
the Montefeltro who is the son by the way of a main,
we though whom we met in Canto 27 of in fair.
And this is why I like to focus on him,
the break between the past and the future,
the sand being always a sort of statement about a project,
about a future product side of the door,
a statement about about the future and,
and,
and uh,
that father ends up in her,
the son ends up in this program,
Total Ledge on the way to redemption.
So there is no chain of natural necessity and causality between the past and the
present and the future.
That is a focus on freedom because once you break that,
that bond of necessity,
you are really opening up inaugurating the idea that we are free,
that we are really free to make ourselves regardless of what antecedents we may
have behind us.
But there's another little detail which is a formal,
it really tells you something about Dante's art.
So he goes long landlines 88 or so.
Then another spoke prey,
so made it that desire beside this five,
which drove the to the uh,
high mount.
What an extraordinary,
extraordinary language about design drawing us we are in.
This is Dante as universe of desire,
where impelled but desire and desire is really what moves us.
We love that moves us.
It's desire that impels us to go one way or the other.
Do Dowe do that with gracious pity.
Help mine.
I was of Montefeltro,
I am boom called.
And I hope now that you are sensitive to this temporal to the Kansas that this
junction intenses are really pointed those out for you.
In the Canto of Google Reno in here to health bone content is asserting his,
uh,
his identity in the mode of the presence presence and detaching himself with the
view of,
of the use of the past tense from the,
the,
um,
the family Montefeltro.
Now the Jovana Mri has had care for me so that I go among this with downcast
brow.
And I said to him,
what force or what chains chains the or adventure adventure more than chance
chances too heavy a word,
and I will come back to this a little bit a little bit later,
where Dante reflects on the significance of which has took the sole far from
compel deal that the bureau praise was never known.
This is an extraordinary scene,
an extraordinary and counter for one very autobiographical reasoning.
And the reason is this is that Dante fought at the battle of [inaudible] was one
the moment of his great maturity.
He is entering into the battle,
the battlefield of life when he discovers that now because of the victory that
the Florentines had income [inaudible] that he also can have claims about
himself,
about his own family and political future.
And how he made me means a victim.
And there have been those who go and claiming with very little evidence as if
you are in a battle.
I don't know how many of you know,
uh,
the field of compel.
Dino is,
it's pretty,
pretty large,
25 miles
east,
uh,
east of Florence.
Uh,
it,
the idea is that those who go on claiming that maybe this is someone that Dante
killed actually in battle and now sort of retrieve them,
brings him back.
There's no evidence for this,
but it is a painful autobiographical moment for that moment when he did
experience violence and he perpetrated violence,
and this is the answer,
ah,
he replied at the foot of the cousin Tino,
rather than answering the questions a battle,
he goes on thinking about his death.
He recounts his death.
This is a poem about births.
You remember,
I always like to say this about the vent of being born and the portentous
quality that being born implies that kind of alterations that we all can,
can bring on the world around us.
Uh,
but the very fact that we were born now he talks about death.
He replied,
the photo Cosentino stream crosses called the Kiano,
which rises above the hermitage in the upper ninth to the place where it's name
is Blas.
I came wounded in the throat,
flying on foot and blood in the plane.
They are lost sight and speech.
I ended on the name of Mary and their fell and only my fresh remained.
I will tell the truth.
And do thou tell it again among the living.
God's angel took me and he from hell cried odour from heaven.
Why does now rob me?
It's one the reason why I'm really reading this passage,
Romney,
to tell you about this notion of the power of time and the power of
retrospection.
Looking back,
that that final moment once life is,
they're the size of moment that,
uh,
confers a coherence and the meaning to one's life.
Okay.
We were born and we are born with certain expectations of what we can do.
But death becomes the revelatory event.
That's fine.
This is really the point of this passage.
But there's another point.
Dante deploys the fame rhetorical genre of the debate,
which he had used in the encounter with the uh,
[inaudible] father.
So that by the sameness of the rhetorical genre,
you are forced to really couple them together.
And yet the point is that of the distance between father and son,
that was the distance in the temporal disjunction between the past and the
present and the future.
The Canto ends with six lines,
which had extraordinary lines where sentimentalist is.
Occasionally I am,
I will go on and even seeing as Tuttle illusion of Dante to his own wife,
it's a,
it's an encounter with a beer.
The Ptolemaic a woman from Sienna.
And clearly this little passage is meant to,
uh,
refocus,
remind us of Francesca in Canto five of unfair.
No,
it's the exact symmetrical cancer.
These are the lines are,
uh,
which I will read.
I will go and reading also in Italian.
You read it in English.
Uh,
Professor Margaret Brooks was asking me to give some evidence of,
uh,
what the Italian language it sounds like.
And uh,
so it's a moment of nostalgia for,
for you too.
I take,
so pray Windar has returned to the world and that rested from the long way.
The third spa spirit fall on the second dude out.
Remember me,
who Amblyopia is a sort of,
uh,
an epitaph who,
who was mistreated by here by,
by the husbands and yet incredibly forgiving and the,
and the word ends with a and the pathogens with uh,
uh,
the word gem,
which is Gemma,
uh,
Dante's wives' name.
Uh,
so one wonders if be a,
also doesn't stay in the kind of sort of wishful thinking on the part of Dante
that his wife,
whom he had because of exile had been forced to leave behind a may also forgive.
That's the point is that introducing this radical category of forgiveness,
which is the true scandal.
If you went to begin again,
then forgiveness is exactly what's demanded.
Let me read the passage in Italian and we move on.
That one to two psoriasis or natural Mundo.
Early posts are too,
they're a lunar via said.
We told her to spiritual sickened record the TDMA.
Okay,
so let the CNN,
me Fay,
this
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] this [inaudible] call us.
We're Gemma.
Now we move tool after this highly.
I find that a passage of a great pathos as are all of them are a great intimacy.
Dante's really involved and justice is obliquely involved with [inaudible].
They both have the same battle on opposite sides.
Uh,
and,
and then this encounter with fear,
they told me we,
we,
we turn into a public and a political canto.
Uh,
and,
and uh,
let me see,
let me just try to explain a couple of things before we move on to something
that I care about here.
Uh,
in terms of the,
the Canto 10 and 11,
that's how he begins Canto six political Canto Canto six of inferno and I can
throw six of paradise.
You know that now,
the simple principle of symmetry at work,
this is not came for six of inferno is about the city of Florence came of
[inaudible] is about Italy and the disarray,
the chaos,
the,
this unity of,
of the country.
Uh,
and he starts when the game of hazard breaks up,
the loser is left disconcert golden over his throws again and sadly learns his
lesson with the other.
All the people go off,
one goes in front,
one seasons him from behind and other it is recited,
recalls himself to his memory.
He does not stop but listens to this one.
And that one,
each to whom he reaches his hand presses on him no longer.
And so he saves himself from the throngs.
Such was I in that dense crowd turning my face to them this way and that,
and by promising I got free from them.
There was the maritime.
And so it's an extraordinary similar
to explain,
that's the burden of the sibling that,
uh,
all the penitents or social priced and seen Dante alive in the,
beyond,
that they would go after him.
He is.
There's a throng of people pressing on him.
That's the simulator,
but they seem really,
that he uses is that of a winner in a game of hazard.
That is to say he's the winner.
Dante's the winner and they all go after him and the old neglect,
Virgil Virgil is the loser and therefore the similarly introduces her language,
which is extraordinary.
It is as if now we're speaking of his salvation,
of the uniqueness of this journey that he is undertaking in terms of a game of
hazard.
We all have been thinking that this is really providential journey and now he is
casting it as if it were just a game of chance.
Here is the word change that he uses hazard.
It's,
it's,
it's an interesting first of all,
from the point of view of,
uh,
of,
of the language of play.
This is playful.
It's a way of almost of casting one salvation as the casting of the,
of the,
of,
of the dice.
A lot a lottery here that someone losing someone,
someone win and then says,
well I was born after the incarnation so I had the possibility of saving myself
and Virgil did not.
It also is an interesting metaphor because it really introduces the question of
play in Dante's theological conception and it's an issue that I will talk about
much more extensively when we reach paradise,
but one thing is clear that Dante understands that the relationship between,
and that's that's all I will say unless you press me a little later,
but we'll talk more about this metaphor.
That antenna understands that the relationship between the soul and God is a
relationship shape by risk on both sides and that this idea of risk that would
seem to be a blind casting of the dice in effect constitutes the freedom that
the human beings can have in the scheme of things.
The whole point of salvation is by using this language of hazard and chance is a
rescue.
It's this engaged from my the idea that God knows it all and we are going to and
we are determined in what we do.
No know Dante saying by focusing on a timebound metaphor is that we are engaged
in a risky relationship and it's in all relationship between God and the soul.
There is this element of danger.
That's it.
That's the metaphor.
Um,
to make it more precise.
So you don't,
you,
you know what I'll be going,
uh,
in the days ahead,
whenever,
uh,
in antiquity we will discuss,
mainly bullied.
This is the most important author,
uh,
the relationship between human freedom and the,
and and God's foreknowledge.
They would always present the case to say that God is outside of time,
or it says being outside of time,
old times converge in God and so that God sees all things in,
uh,
in the present.
So that should really,
God is here.
It's a point of view,
which is transcendent and therefore a synoptic.
And we are in a diachronic world,
past,
present,
and future.
But everything is at the same time we think that we live,
we live in a world where we do not know what tomorrow may bring us.
What are the decisions we make now have already been,
uh,
what kind of,
it's there.
I'm predictable,
or they have been determined by things that escape our control.
But God knows,
and this is the breathe in scheme of harmonizing God's foreknowledge and human
freedom.
It doesn't take too much to,
to realize that this is really a little bit of,
uh,
the illusion because you know that I'm free or am I not free?
Uh,
it may be that God knows it all,
but doesn't mean that he wills that I,
that I do what I do.
He knows,
but he does not will it.
And yet,
you know,
he knows and I'm here and I don't know.
So my own freedom is still a little bit of a rhetorical.
Dante does it differently.
It's a departure from bleachers.
The relationship within God's for a knowledge for knowledge and the souls,
uh,
being in time is one that that introduces the question of chains and hazard.
Uh,
and that involves God,
both God and the soul.
And to be very precise.
He doesn't say it here.
And that's why I hesitated to get into that.
I would like to work with a text to be,
to make this very clear,
the issue is that in a love relationship between God and the soul,
we are always at risk or is at risk.
And if you accept the principal of the love economy regulating the unit,
which does Dante does,
certainly does,
then you understand this notion of hazard,
uh,
in,
in a,
not as a principal of a,
uh,
just a,
a change in the sense of,
uh,
um,
casual,
a blind,
the randomness,
but in,
in a sense of,
uh,
of this risk proposition,
risk element,
then they can talk,
uh,
goes on after this particular method.
What goes on with another meeting between two poets?
Uh,
yes,
please.
The economy,
the economy of love.
The question,
the clarification is what do I mean by the love economy?
Uh,
the Dante's universe,
it's a universe of love and that's how creation takes place.
The creation of the university,
of the creation of human beings.
So we are the involvement that we as every soul has with God is one of love and
justice and the relationship between say Beatrice and Dante.
There is an element of risk in loving what is the risk in loving there can think
of several.
I think we are all grown up for grown ups to understand that one loves and one
may not be reciprocated in love.
That's a pretty bad risk.
Certainly it's a risk of God who creates a may not be loved,
which is the story of where this obedience is and it certainly is the
existential experience of human beings to be involved with someone other we love
their own person with then we say wisely,
I was loving the wrong person.
I'm being ironic.
But with that idea of wisdom or discovering that indeed in every religion there
is time,
feelings change.
We have so many ways of thinking about it and there is a,
uh,
dentist response is uh,
look,
uh,
he,
he likes figures.
Who should,
we should talk about this.
Like Francis who goes to prey on the cliffs at night because he wants to
dramatize the idea that even a prayer put you at risk of being heard or not
being heard,
of being disappointed of discovering that the world does not go the way you want
it to go.
And that which is true in prayer is truly love.
Okay.
That's what I was saying.
I wasn't saying anything from uh,
uh,
more than that.
In Canto six,
also the political canto,
there is an encounter between two poets.
One is Virgil with,
um,
eh sort of dialogue who is a man from port.
They all share the same birth place mantra across the centuries they meet.
And the very idea of mantra,
they ask,
uh,
virtual virtual sal saying mantra,
clearly playing with a famous,
uh,
epitaph.
I think [inaudible] the line interrupts.
There's this man mantra or made me know the famous epitaph written on a in
Naples where virtual is,
is buried a man to a made me.
Um,
and uh,
uh,
the,
the South Calibri took away,
took me away.
I sang the f the,
the arms,
the anemia,
the herds,
the Georgics and the story about the bucolic,
the fields,
it's just,
just in two lines,
the account of his whole life.
So it's that saying Mantua I think alluding to this birthplace,
once again,
the birth.
And so they're low in,
he embrace this,
embrace,
this existential encounter,
this other little moment which is in substantial because they can't really
embrace their spirits and other failure after the one that we saw with Cassela
in,
in Canto,
in Canada to have a of Purgatorio,
uh,
that triggers Dante's political invective against Italy.
It's the moment of which I will read very briefly and I will not read the whole
thing,
but it's an invective,
um,
uh,
this the kind of civic sense of responsibility.
Uh,
and this,
uh,
um,
all Manch one,
uh,
this is line 75 o'clock canto six,
and the gentle leader began man to our,
and the shade who had been all wrapped within himself.
Sprained,
told him from the place where he was saying,
Oh man,
I am sort of Dello,
uh,
of the city.
He's a province,
how port?
But he wrote in province and,
uh,
from,
from mantra and the [inaudible] and the one embrace the other.
Look at this phrase,
which is extraordinary.
It was an Italian.
Now I feel that I can read things to Margaret Attack Tech.
Read it.
Kalyan is freely as I care.
Illume loved Barbara Java.
Um,
I returned to this construction in a moment.
One embrace the other.
It's,
it's,
it's what I call a,
it's a phrase of reciprocity.
That's where one embrace the other,
the reciprocity of affections across time.
Okay.
Dante begins his incredible or victory operational.
He's attack against in sleeved Italy.
Um,
and,
and look how the Italy enslaved hostile of misery,
number of metaphor,
ship without pilot in great tempest,
no princess among the provinces.
But Bravo so eager was that no posole only for the dear name of his city to give
welcome to their,
to its citizens.
And now in the they live living are never free from war.
And of those one wall and Moat Shuttin one knows at the other and other,
uh,
another line that seems to have a sort of uh,
grim version of the reciprocity earlier one embrace the other.
Now one knows that the other,
but if you look at the Italian,
it's really slightly different.
English doesn't give that this translation at least,
uh,
one is just in ta line 82.
No,
not stand,
nuisance aware live oil and Lula see roll there.
One is a reflexive form.
The other one does not.
And the moment of violence,
Dante uses the verb cro role in the reflective form in order to imply that the
exchange is an exchange.
That it all is terms of oneself,
one knows at the other full oneself.
Therefore it reverses and denies very process.
There is reciprocity are the action of reciprocity indicated by the previous,
uh,
the previous,
a phrase.
I could also,
uh,
emphasize a couple of details here where Dante says,
welcome to the citizens.
And now in,
uh,
indeed I living at an ever free from war.
And those whom one wall emote Shuttin.
It's very,
you do know that the word for community which,
which we always use right community,
it's a word that written biologically comes from
the Latin for war mania community meant and,
and stems from is a concept from the sharing of walls,
houses piling in and built one on top of the other.
That's the idea of a community.
The shared the shared walls of the city,
which we are now a seen as,
uh,
viewed as separating one from the other.
And then this will continue with the lack of laws and the families,
including the mantle use and copulates for you Shakespeare lovers or mentioned
here.
And uh,
uh,
and then Dante ends up with a,
um,
on online,
the one 25 with a returning to Florence and the little,
uh,
clearly bitter satire.
My Florence,
they'll miss well beer east with this digression,
uh,
come back to this metaphor in the moment,
which does not touch the thanks to the people who are sorry,
resourceful.
So Dante talks about it.
Everybody turns to him,
federal sex with your vocation or Florence,
he's calling this,
this poem,
this,
this invective a digression,
which literally means that it does not belong.
The poem that Nana is stepping out of the economy of the poem and talking on his
own voice.
It's a digression.
That's where we call it a day.
Rashford right where you are.
You use a particular language that doesn't really belong to the general protein
theme.
But then the meaning of this digression is made really clear later when he says,
uh,
which does not touch the how ironic.
Of course he saying literally this digression,
you are so much better than all these other towns.
That's the irony.
Florence is no better.
Therefore this digression,
it doesn't really concern you,
but it can also be understood in another way.
And then when another more tragic and most sinister way,
this digression does not touch you,
my language will not affect you,
but the whole state with in all its ambiguity,
it becomes one of the reflection on the impotence of the poetic language to
affect the historical are the unfolding of,
uh,
of history.
The ordering of the city.
It is as if Dante,
we're a,
we're here.
That the relationship between the voice of the poet and the political order is
one of inevitable rupture.
So Nancy who test to improve and change,
that's clearly the,
the thrust of the passage.
And the thrust of the invective also also declared that powerlessness,
uh,
in his,
his doing so good.
We are doing very well with time.
So I have a chance to read a little seen Dante moves on talking about the first
night of purgatorial will take place and uh,
he takes in the so called Valley of the princes were and knew God and another
God is going to be described,
which in many ways,
uh,
fulfills the God in a limbo,
in can tall four of in fan on,
you know,
don't,
don't think has this motives that keep reappearing.
And here it's more than a natural beauty of the place.
It's,
it's,
it's uh,
they're precious stones implying the pool got Oreo.
Is that the world of transition for trends and souls?
That is something abiding about this place.
And then Dante moves on,
uh,
around to read a paragraph here,
with,
um,
uh,
the,
the meeting with a princess I wanted to do about it,
but I want to read it.
First passage,
which is an evening song.
Uh,
Dante's Dante,
the pilgrim now is taken with the nostalgia for his whole home town.
It is a,
um,
the pilgrimage of desire,
which is the poem.
Write a poem of desire.
Desire for God is higher for Beatrice.
Now turns into the desire for the comfort and the shelter of the home he had
lost.
So re,
listen to this passage.
It's,
it's written in many ways in,
in,
along the lines or province.
Our poetry over nostalgia and listen to the acid and says is the first six,
seven lines of Canto Eight,
uh,
listen to the essence is the casting structures of the sounds.
I,
which I'm not going to point out to you.
You can do that on your own.
Uh,
era.
Jalil
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].
So the squealer Dylan get back until June.
Luke Pangea case in water do coming.
Chaya render Wianno Ludia Emirati,
one of the La Sueur coal tar.
He their command and then they hear here,
I'm not going to be able to read it,
but to tell you how the poem should be read.
Then they're going here,
him and medieval him.
They blue cheese anti-terror amendments on which if we were really at the time,
I would come to to class with the whole Latin him because we,
Dante gives only the first three words,
but clearly we are supposed to hear the whole thing,
uh,
about the dangers of the night sense that Tinnitus,
soft fraud with phantasms and that that will intrude on the,
the powers of judgment of the various holes.
Dante's own included,
uh,
with Ken Tunein.
Dante moves from,
as he does in every country.
Nine Canto,
nine marks,
the rupture from a particular area of,
uh,
of the poem too.
Then other,
another,
remember Canto nine of inferno and the encounter with the failed and counter
with a medusa.
That passage into the city of this.
Now with Ken [inaudible],
Dante moves into purgatory proper.
And so we'll go with the cattle pen 11 and 12.
We're not going to be able to do all three cantos to there.
So we'll return to some of the things that I will say now about Canto 10 and 11
that I hope to cover.
Um,
um,
how is purgatorial that part?
What is this purification proper going to take place?
This is the ordering Dan two will go on the so called seven deadly sins.
I don't know that you know what they are.
Uh,
but the first one was just see them.
The first one is,
and they go from spiritual sins.
Pride is the root of all sins,
uh,
to,
to lust at the end,
um,
in every representation of,
uh,
of,
of this sin.
Dante precedes it with their presentation of its opposite virtue so that we have
humility in Canto 10.
And then in Canada,
11 punished pride first of all,
as if Dante has to learn that which is going to witness a little later.
In a sense,
it's the,
um,
the,
the uh,
absolute reversal of the economy of,
of inferno and purgatory.
You may remember that I said last time that the incredible,
uh,
quality of the structure of the poem is that Dante wants us to see experiences
of evil in,
in fair,
no first so that when we get to purgatory and paradise,
we really have the change to appreciate what the good is and appreciate what the
absence of the good may be,
but evil really,
really generates.
And then genders here.
Now he changes all of this in a,
in,
in porter,
he starts with,
with the representation of the virtue of humility.
And then the same,
um,
the representational,
the virtue of humility takes place through the language of art.
Dante approaches that cliff and know the size of the cliff.
He sees three sculptures and bolding,
uh,
examples of humility.
The word,
uh,
pride,
which in Italian is,
you know,
we have the English superb.
In Italian,
we call it [inaudible] to the word superb.
You add IAA,
which is pride.
Uh,
uh,
they were the humility.
He's Italian.
The same thing as UU minister.
They will,
the humility means comes from the ground.
The sense of the,
of,
of being down,
of being the idea that one is really a,
with let's say,
the feet on the ground,
the very opposite of superbeets,
which implies some kind of a immoderate flight away,
a sense of the,
the view of the over man,
right?
The idea of being a superman,
some here that someone who wants to transcend the,
uh,
the limitations of this world and being human.
Um,
the,
the word folk,
humility and the word for human heaven.
This same victimology in case you,
you wonder where it comes.
The all mall,
h,
o,
m,
O which means man,
they Latin comes from Hoummos.
We are cold man,
human beings because we come from,
from the earth and we are close to the earth and we'll return to the earth.
Uh,
we come from the earth and are returning to the earth.
the idea of humility is the same,
the same notions.
So there is a kind of implicit connection etymologically between the two.
The two words that two terms,
um,
uh,
one,
one more,
uh,
remark to make this whole idea of having a couple of remarks before I go in with
the text.
Um,
but with serve you for the rest of proven story,
the idea of um,
um,
having the,
the humor,
the virtues and the end devices.
Our first one and the other seem to cast purgatory,
but it's not really that way,
uh,
as a variant of a medieval poetic form called Comark Markia,
which means the battle of the battle of thoughts.
Uh,
CECO market,
by the way,
this is a Latin poem,
one of the early Latin poem by this Latin Spanish poet called Prudential's.
Uh,
the,
so it's a,
it's a kind of secret market,
the battle of thoughts of contradictory thoughts.
The second thing that I have to say,
it's more important for the poetics of Dante.
Keep in mind that the whole poetic mode of Purgatorio,
unlike the poetic mode of inferno is played out in predatorial through the
imagination,
art,
images,
memories,
phantasms.
And that was,
we're really in a world which is in between their bodies and souls,
the world.
The middle ground of the imagination.
And now we have the world of art,
a work of art that Dante says,
and I read from Kantar 10 at the very beginning.
Um,
I just,
I want to give you,
this is,
it's a,
it's an extraordinary,
uh,
I don't,
I'm,
I don't want to go into excessive detail,
but I have to do it this time when we were within the threshold Canto 10,
the very beginning of the gate,
which the soul's perverse love this user's purgatory is all,
eh,
a sequence of variations on love.
That's the moral law of purgatory.
All sins in purgatory or sense of either gurus use the,
we give love to the wrong object or we love too much in terms of what,
how we are being loved back or we love too little.
These are the three general subdivisions of purgatory.
Okay,
so that's perverse.
Love this.
Users making the crooked way seemed straight by the resounding,
I heard it closed again,
and if I had turned my eyes to it,
what excuse would have served for the fault reflection on what happened before
we were climbing through a cleft in the rock,
which kept bending one way in the other,
of course,
around the mountain.
Okay.
That's really what the languages like a wave that comes and goes.
When my leader began here,
there is need to use some skill in keeping close to this side or that will it
turn turns away.
The cliff is there's an abyss and their needs it,
so it's an invitation to prudence along the way,
and this made us step so scanned that they're winning.
Moon had regain its bed to sing to rest before we were fourth from the needle's
eye,
but we were free and out in the open above where the mountain draws back.
I really am both uncertain of our way.
We know now this.
This has become a sort of formulaic expression of the uncertainties of this
exile.
As he moves up the mountain,
we stopped on a level place more solitary than a desert track from its edge
bordering on the void to the foot of them off the bank,
which rises a sheer would measure er three times a man's body and as far as my
eye could make its flight.
Now on the left hand,
now underwrite that terrace that seemed to me,
they say,
what is all this about?
What I want to point out is that Dante is measuring the whole landscape in terms
of the measure of a human being.
He's using the human beings,
a human being as the measure and all that.
It's main the measure.
You have heard that expression,
right?
Are we the measure with a measure of what creation or with a measure what we
should do?
This is exactly the point of the Kantar.
It was pride means and in inordinate love and believe in our own excellence.
Pride means that we do not think that we are.
We can be measured by others that we want to become the measure for others or
that we really do not belong where others may think we belong.
That's what pride is seen.
Very common.
Who Do you think?
Who Do you think you are?
Who Don't?
You know who I am.
This is the language we use and it's pride.
I always like to say that are never really proud when we are dealing with our
janitor.
Yeah.
Not Proud of that becomes so human.
So,
so good.
We are all as proud with those when danger,
our sense of our own measure,
who seemed to take the wrong measure of us.
So Dante is starting with the idea of measurement and that comes back.
This is the crucial metaphor.
And that come back to that.
How do we measure what is human?
And there is no human.
One thing is clear that pride,
suburbia means an inordinate love of one's own excellence.
Uh,
we are really fast superiors,
uh,
we think than everybody anybody else could have taught us.
And then he goes on,
uh,
looking at,
um,
images made on the white marble,
such,
such that not only public liters,
but nature would be put to shame their extraordinary metaphor or how are they
talking about,
uh,
about measure,
about order.
Uh,
these are,
these are works of art produced by the hand of God directory.
God is an artist and God has made these images,
but it's such that nature,
which as you know,
is the daughter of God and uh,
and,
and the mother of the arts.
Uh,
and also notice the famous political leaders,
Greek scholar pull el Greek sculptor qualities would be put to shame or ready.
There is the sense of rivalry within the pattern of generation of arts.
Okay.
Uh,
that's the first thing.
And then the first image that we see is image of the Angel Gabriel,
the Messenger who came to earth.
That's humility.
That's immediately it came toward the descent,
the descent of the high becoming low.
While the human beings who are low,
one to think of themselves as very high.
The Angel who came to Earth with the decree of the many years whipped for peace
that are open heaven from its wrong interdict appeared before us.
So truly Greven,
they're in a gracious attitude that it did not seem a silent image.
That's God's art.
But very clear,
there's no difficulty in understanding this art.
One would have sworn he said the first words of the Angel Gabriel during the
Annunciation.
They don't see Asian is the story of the humility whereby of politically God
becomes man.
So that's the descent and other form of,
of,
of only the,
the humility of Mary in accepting the mandate,
but also the,
the,
the idea of the dissent.
By the way,
let me just point out of this.
Avi is where we call a boost profit on,
I have spelled the word out for you.
For a VA,
it's very conventional.
In medieval medieval literature.
The idea that,
uh,
Mary becomes that the one who reverses the role of eve.
Okay.
With eve,
there's the,
the loss of the garden and the fall with air,
with Rv,
there is now the turning of the key as it were.
And the redemption for she was imaged there who turn the key to open the supreme
love.
And in her bearing she had this wonderful imprinted,
this word imprinted h and Sheila.
They,
she acknowledges her.
Mary acknowledges ancillary role.
She is a servant and she acknowledges herself as a servant.
And now I alongside with this what we could call an ethical education,
Dante's rice to learn what humility is.
There's an ethical education.
Learn about what this humility is about.
There is also an aesthetic education going on.
Simple tennis after all,
Dante's really looking at art.
So the question is what is the relationship between the virtual and art?
How can the tool be together?
And to give you an idea of how complicated the problem is is then the next
candle Dante goes on meeting all the painters.
You read Kant 11 Jocko and Shima Bohr who are emblems of people who invest their
productions with an inordinate val sense of their,
of its value.
Then Dante puts himself,
puts his friends.
We though Cavalcanti you remember the two wheels and we though we need sadly
says one weedo removed the other we'd have from its nest and now the third
person has come meaning himself who probably were route both of them.
What a proud statement it is as if the artists are always prone to this salt of
inordinately idea of who they are and what their value maybe.
So art and humility and pride that this is the issue,
the ethical education and the aesthetic education.
What is the aesthetic education?
Virgil is telling Dante how to look.
That's really the most complicated thing for those of you who are doing art
history.
That's really what it's about.
How do we look through the eyes really revealed to us,
do not keep their mind all in one part.
That's,
that's the looking,
the belief that we,
or the temptation to lose sight of the totality of things and not,
uh,
and,
and just taking one part for the whole,
uh,
do not keep their mind on in one part said the card master who had me on that
side of him where the heart lives on the left so that I turned my face.
And so beyond Mary on the same side as he,
that prompted me another story set on the rock.
So Dante has to learn how to look and where he's looking at her stories story,
the word this Greek for those of you who know some Greek it comes from I saw and
I never rate.
And it's the same etymology firms for story and history.
This is a little better of an allegory of history where it's as if Dante's
really begins with the New Testament,
the story of Mary.
Now we're going to see a picture from the Old Testament,
David dancing in front of the Ark and then an episode of Trajan,
the emperor who is an example of humility is or see him in a,
and the point is that the whole of history is a,
an allegory of humility.
And that's God's heart.
That's what Dante has God's represent for us.
So,
um,
Mary,
et Cetera,
they're carved in the same marble where the car to Knox and drawing the sacred
ark on account of which meant fear an office not committed to them in front
people appeared.
And the whole company divided into seven choir's made two of my sensors.
Hey,
the one,
no the other.
Yes,
they saying in the same way at the smoke of the incense I was in image,
their eyes and nose were in contradiction with yes and no there.
The humbles hammers,
David,
when before the blessed vessel Gert up and dancing at the time he was both more
and less than king,
opposite figured on the,
at the window of a great palace.
Mccall looked on like a woman vexed and scornful.
This is really,
uh,
the story that is told in Samuel and the Bible in Dante's really reinterpreting
it for us.
So I beg you to repair a little attention to some of these episodes.
First of all,
David is humbling himself.
His dancing,
he lifts up his um,
his fault,
his dress and just dancing out of joy.
It's an episode that is used as one of the many cases and so called Ludic
theology,
playful,
theologists intrusion that in,
in,
uh,
in the plan of salvation,
there is always the presence of his comedy,
this comic idea and David embodies that.
Okay.
And then there's this little phrase which you must have noticed that peer so
often in this candle,
moreover than this cancer than ever before in the whole point,
more,
less,
more and less.
It is as if it's impossible to use or find in a canter where measure is the
issue,
the precision about where we are,
who we are and what we are doing.
But one thing is clear that opposite to David,
that is his wife call sitting at the window different perspective and what she
sees,
this is art.
This is a question of perspective.
What she says.
She is so angry at David because he is by his action of dancing in front of the
Ark is humiliating himself.
He's losing his state as king.
He's losing his stature as Kang.
The fact is that for Dante,
McCall is completely missing the point.
It is a stance of someone who thinks that she's superior stance or some of who's
sitting at the great I the window had great palace,
will not have anything to do with what's below her.
We are entering the world or the domain or what pride may be.
What's wrong with pride then why pride may really be a sin.
Pride may not be a sin because of we want to reach higher than we are.
That's probably okay.
What makes pride the sin is that we tend to have contempt for what we think is
below us.
That's really the displacement.
It blinds us,
so I'm,
I'm introducing here since this is a world of art,
the notion of a perspective we've been talking about perspective.
Pride is tied to perspective because he said by being proud,
I think that I have within myself,
I certainly have a view of myself that may be at odds with the reality of me.
Right?
Certainly this is the case of not David,
but it's the case of McCall.
The third episode is I think even more,
more interesting and then we'll see what's going to happen.
Um,
the,
I moved my feet from where I was to examine close to the end.
And other part of this,
how do you examine what is an aesthetic education?
Uh,
how do you look for images?
I hand another story which I saw gleaming with y white beyond me.
Call the pic the there.
Now the third episode is from secular history,
Roman history.
So you have Old Testament,
New Testament,
Old Testament,
the Roman,
yeah,
secular history.
There was the glorious deed of the Roman Prince who's worth moved Gregory to his
great victory.
I mean the emperor Trajan and the poor widow was his bridle in a posture of
grief and tears,
the place about him,
Sim trampled and thronged with nights and the eagles and the gold above them
move visibly in the wind.
The poor woman among all the,
these seem to say,
Lord avenge me for my son that is dead for whom I'm stricken.
And he to answer her,
wait til now our return,
he's going on to Romania,
the Asia.
If you see the column of Trajan in Rome,
it's still the,
the,
the monument document of that expedition.
Uh,
wait,
not return.
And she,
my Lord,
like one whose grief is urgent,
if they're returned not and he,
he that is in my place will do it for the,
and she watched shall another's goodness avail the,
if thou are forgetful of their known now take comfort for us.
Fulfill my duty before I go.
Justice requires and compassion with.
It's the story of Trajan who gets off his high horse levels with the little
widow,
they diminutives or Dante languages of humility,
the little widow and,
and administers and gives her,
it gives her justice because for Dante,
the perfect emperor and Trajan certainly is the perfect emperor.
Must be,
must have the attributes of mercy and justice.
And he gives yeah,
evidence of that if for who site,
et Cetera.
Now,
um,
ah,
that's the drama,
not developed.
Dante Cenovus,
he has understood this images and the meaning of his images and the,
uh,
well I'm just going to tell you about this little drama and we stop here,
are what I was taking delight in no problem.
And picking the light after all,
this is God's law,
God's art.
Uh,
so having delight in itself,
uh,
is,
is part of the appreciation of this art at the images of soap.
Great.
Uh,
humility's I think that the oxymoron is deliberate.
The greed,
humility is Dhea to side tool for the craftsmen sake.
I love them because they were made by God virtual prompt him.
See on this side,
many people that port murmured.
But calming with slow steps,
they will direct us to the other stairs.
And now here is dentist drama.
My eyes,
which were looking intently.
We're not slow in turning to him,
being eager for new sites.
He yields to the temptations of the eye.
Have you ever heard about the three temptations?
The pride of life,
the,
um,
the pride of the eyes or the curiosity of the,
and the,
and,
uh,
and the,
and the pride of the over the heart.
But I would,
and the three old temptations are present here,
but I would not have the reader,
Dante's touring to us.
And then apostrophe s he has done before fall away from good resolve for hearing
how God wheels that the debt they paid do not do well on the form is telling us
not to care about the images as such of the torment.
Think of what follows thinker worst.
It can not go beyond the great judgment he saw to them is make a preemptive
strike.
Don't worry about the peculiar form of the art.
Look at the meaning of the art and he can't,
but that's what he's wants us to do.
He says,
but look what he says to Virgil Mass that I begin,
that which I see coming to us does not seem to me persons.
And I know not what they are.
Fuse is my sight.
What an incredible contrast between what Dante had seen with God's images or
clear to him.
But now that he's seeing some human beings who are doubled under massive
boulders,
if that's the punishment inflicted on the proud to put them and press them
against the earth,
he does recognize them.
If it's as if his aesthetic education has been for nothing,
it is ethical.
Education has been for nothing.
He had no difficulty in decipher in God's heart,
which is so clear and,
and luminous.
But now he does not want to identify with what he sees.
He reads,
haven't bulls.
Mikel from high up,
does not want to have anything to do with David.
This is the exactly the same problem that Dante is facing.
He has a,
he had no problem with Gabriel.
The descent of Gabriel has no problem with,
uh,
with Trajan,
but he himself is and willing to identify with those that he believes are uh,
uh,
beneath him.
And then he goes on,
um,
of virtual experience,
the grievous nature of the tournament,
double stem to the ground so that my eyes at first were in debate about them,
but he says they are really human beings like you.
And then Dante goes into a further,
uh,
apostrophe to all Christians calling a himself super,
super superb Nutanix Christianity.
The Italian line is actually very interesting for a reasonable,
I'll tell you in a moment,
look at line one 21,
oh,
super big Kristianne misery.
Lastly,
there is an incredible contrast between the word superior,
meaning superior,
right?
A claim or superiority and the word lassie,
which means lapsed having foreign.
So within the same line,
you capture the,
to this dynamic or how we want to be up and how we go into,
the more,
the higher up you want to go there,
the quicker we seem to be falling.
Uh,
or various V we re wretches mistranslation who are sick in the mines vision and
put your trust in backwards steps.
Steps.
Do you not perceive that we are,
warms born to form the angelic butterfly?
And I want to stress this shift in pronouns.
Do you not perceive Dante is literally taking the higher ground?
We do not know.
He knows,
right?
Do Ury,
he's,
he's preaching to us.
Do you not perceive,
but then he,
with the subsequent Pronoun that we are warms,
he,
uh,
literally,
erases the distance between himself and the readers to himself and the other
Christians.
He places himself on the same ground where we are.
That's the quality of the double voice of Dante systematically punctuated this
text as claim over transcendence,
superior perspective.
Because after all,
he really has seen the whole,
uh,
the unfolding of,
of God's cosmos.
He did.
He has witnessed it,
but at the same time he descends and is part of a common plate.
That's really what the lie is.
Do you not perceive that we are,
warms born to form the angelic butterfly?
The,
it's an illusion that the word for butterfly,
northern Italian.
But in,
um,
in the Roman Sarcophagi,
uh,
in antiquity,
whether they are in,
uh,
Exxon profiles,
if you happen to go there,
you go to [inaudible] where there was a room and uh,
um,
uh,
Roman cemetery,
you would always see a butterfly imprinted on the sarcophagus because the Greek
word for butterfly is Seca.
It's the same word for the soul at the butterfly.
And by putting the implement of the butterfly,
the indicated at death,
the soul finally would be capable of flying off toward delight and told the
creator.
So Dante is clearly using and,
and remembering this kind of a motif that he has seen that source to judgments
that defense.
Why does your mind the fraud so high since we are,
as it were,
imperfect insects at the warm that is undeveloped.
The language of a metamorphosis.
We are in the process of making ourselves both alive and in the penitential
world or purgatory.
And then how he ends up with an Acorn,
no graphic motif that recapitulates the whole iconographic element that make up
the poem are there.
The can talk 10 as for core book to support ceiling,
a roof and figure sometimes since joining the knees do the breast which begets
from it's hard reality,
real distress in him that says it in such a posture.
I saw these when I look carefully.
They were indeed Ben town more and less and as they had more and less on their
back and he that had most patients in his look seem to buy his weeping to say,
I can no more.
What is this about?
What is this story about?
Well,
the stories first of all about this,
this passage,
it's about the fact that Dan has just warned us not to pay attention to the form
and to look at the meaning of a particular message.
Now he returns to us and focuses on the form was what he's describing.
This oh called cariatides human forms that if you go maybe in New York you may
see them,
but it's certainly in European cities.
This human forms,
I seem to be buttressing edifices and buildings and they are decorative,
but auntie saying the form matters.
We can not really go to the ultimate meaning by bypassing the form.
So he's literally a,
by picking up the,
the uh,
the sculpture or Motif of the Kantor returning to this idea we shall see cause
I,
I have to leave you hanging on this problem or prospective assembly,
the 11 and 12 and continue.
Um,
um,
and therefore the meaning of art,
how art can change a moral perception of the world.
That's the idea in which you are all wondering,
have been wondering where your questions are.
What is Dante's understanding of art?
It's so dangerous and it can be of course,
but there is a role that art can play in altering our perception.
A moral perception in an effect form becomes a way to go to understand,
uh,
the moral world and the moral terms in which you are.
We shall see this,
uh,
next time.
Let's see if there are questions now.
MMM.
The,
the real la,
I think we are approaching the,
the heart of the matter in purgatory.
The relationship between ethics and aesthetics and,
and what I really pointed out so far,
then it's this idea that Dante is trying to find out what is the measure for
human beings because we cannot say,
well it's pride.
What criteria if I want to reach,
you know,
reach for what it's so far away from me.
Why should that be viewed?
Is,
is a sin of pride.
Um,
so what are the criteria?
What is the context in which we can really talk of pride and why is humility and
a better,
we haven't touched any of this yet.
Um,
one thing that is clear is that Dante is for now,
uh,
on the one hand giving examples of art and humility,
making mistakes.
The confusion of his perception.
He says they cannot quite figure out what are the shapes or is,
is there something disfigured he cannot quite identify with,
they cannot recognize them.
And then claims that we really should be,
should looking at the meaning and the ultimate meaning of things.
But then he returns and valorizes the idea of form.
We cannot bypass form in,
in art or an experience we can not buy.
We can not skip the idea of time.
That's really what,
what existentially it amounts to.
That's all I need have said.
And then maybe explain to you a few etymological or connections,
humility and the human,
uh,
the meaning of history.
Uh,
and,
and introduced this principle principle of perspective that I have been talking
about before,
but this is really connected with the representational art,
uh,
perspective.
What is the,
what kind of perspective that's arts and give us.
We all know that in art we use perspectives,
especially with the modern language of art,
the modern language of painting.
Ever since the 15th Century explicitly discusses the question,
we'll perspective.
I see the world are called into the position that I occupy in it and the
position that occupy in it reveals things to me which are unique and it reduced
at the same time implies,
it also implies,
but this is not the case.
The possibility of manipulating space.
The 15th century Renaissance Discovers that space is not unalterable and fixed,
but it can be manipulated.
Right with dealing with up to that point,
maybe we're dealing with time and the manipulation of time.
You don't have to watch a football game to know what I mean about the
manipulation of time,
but then there is such a thing as manipulation of space.
I can create the space I can make of this small space.
Something appear large space is not a fixed entity.
That's what what,
what perspective comes to me and in the 15th century for Dante perspective is
connected to an inner world.
What is my perspective of myself?
What is my sense of the measure of things?
How do I view the world?
Mccall gives one answer as you can be angry about,
but David does misunderstanding the whole point of David.
What does he,
she misunderstand about David that in humiliating himself he had really found
himself higher by the idea of humiliation of self,
which exactly that of Mary and which is exactly that of the story of Trajan.
So how do you show me call does not understand the reversibility of positions.
That's really the argument so far.
And I think that Dante's making a big deal with pride because pride,
the sin is the root,
the spiritual root of all of all evils.
Let me see if there was some,
some,
some questions that I can,
um,
I have a few minutes please.
Why does Dante have trouble sympathizing with the centers in purgatory or the
people on the ground when he doesn't have trouble doing the same thing?
And in fairness,
what,
why does Dante is trouble sympathizing with the centers employee,
especially here because in,
in,
and I mean he even kicked some of the heads [inaudible] condom in his sympathy.
But uh,
uh,
what is necessary?
He just,
he has had its head.
Then the Canto 32,
uh,
or the guy was frozen on the,
and stuck and not in,
in ice.
Uh,
it wasn't pretty,
it wasn't pretty.
But here it's true.
Especially now he has,
he's,
he,
he declares this his confusion.
It may be because,
uh,
you know,
I couldn't,
I did not know what these forms are.
And I think they have to do with the whole question of what did he learn first
of all,
from,
from the images that he saw because he know a virtual had just taught him how to
look.
Right?
You look here,
you move around a don't stay in one place.
You can look underneath.
So that's one problem.
What is it?
What is a moral and an aesthetic education.
And then he's just also,
I think indicating the whole idea.
What is it ever possible to look at the world more of this next time is this
engaged spectators.
Think of ourselves in the theater,
which is an image that I probably will bring in and discuss.
You know,
you go to the theater and you really,
uh,
sometimes you,
you know,
we all feel that we should jump on the stage and rescue the damsel in distress
or whatever.
And yet,
you know,
you may see someone who do,
who can do that,
but many of us want,
we want to be unaffected by it.
That's what Dante's doing.
He would like to be,
to feel how he is no longer like any of these sinners.
That's the mistake is making.
It's,
it's really that he said it's an indifference calming to him from something
Akin.
They're not exactly to me,
calls,
sure sense of herself.
I have nothing to do with the mob here.
You know what is west of what?
This,
this is the king.
I don't want to even be his wife.
That's what Dante's doing in,
in,
uh,
in that scene.
I do not want to be with this kind of disfigured lowly forms of life.
I am better.
I have seen God's heart and I've learned about God's out.
Do you see the morals and spiritual confusion that this kind of drama is going
to generate in him?
And that's the answer.
The one who reflects beautifully on this,
I will bring the passage in,
but I would like you to read it if you can.
A book two of the confessions of Santa's Gastin because so the customer loves to
go.
I mean,
he does.
He doesn't like to go to the spectacles at the coliseum because they're so
vulgar.
And beneath him.
Right?
Uh,
but he loves to go to the theater and he has extraordinary refraction.
What does it mean to be unaffected in the theater?
How we'll have to understand my discomfort at the theater.
It's the very image Dante users at the end of Canto 10.
I remember when he says that we see characters which we know of phony and yet
they can inspire some kind of distress and paraphrasing very poorly.
The last paragraph,
the last lines of Purgatorio 10,
is it possible to ever be indifferent spectators of the tool more around us?
What and what's at stake when I say,
well,
these things don't touch me,
um,
have nothing to do with me and Dante saying they always touch us,
picks time for him to understand that.
And I think that he's unveiling that he's,
he's,
he's showing it to us and Canto 10.
Okay,
please
connection between.
Yes,
very good.
Do I think that we can draw a connection between form and time and continue?
We had to make a reflection on that.
And then also if there's some way to giants and notion of futurity is time.
And the notion of
eternity as time,
time,
time necessary to beginnings with the idea of an art form,
which is sort of like a fixed and mutable thing.
The question is since up,
I think that was implied if I didn't say it and know what I was saying,
that there is a connection between four men time.
Uh,
the,
the struggle.
They were,
the question that becomes,
we usually think of form or something which is fixed.
How can that be part of the world of time?
Well,
in a number of ways,
I would say that the full Dante saying,
first of all,
witnessing,
watching history,
therefore it has a kind of unfolding and he discusses art in fort in terms of a
metamorphosis,
ongoing process of change that includes id of type.
One way in which jock taught really different shades.
When we're going to see next can't or it's not an arbitrary relation here that
are making the distinguishes himself from Byzantine mosaics is that he
introduces a history.
Painting is a series of,
of of elements and you've got to keep looking at all of them.
So it's a form.
It's unalterable quality.
The form indicates forms change.
There's a history of forms to begin with.
I could
generalize there,
my answer,
uh,
the,
in the,
in a way,
as a metamorphic sequence.
Okay?
So from that point of view,
form sense of all time,
in fact,
he says,
you know,
whenever you see a particular scene or void,
which we're seeing,
Auntie,
that's what it means.
Now,
that is the occlusion of time.
That is an eclipsing of time.
Let me just go to the ideal essence.
The ideal point to when you're reading a poem,
you're reading appointment.
Of course,
the form is changing,
but unless you know the beginning and you could start from the beginning and you
read through I time you come to the end,
you'll miss the point about the poem,
right?
I mean,
I do.
Um,
you got to read.
You've got to be in time and the novel gotta read Proust,
get it full cheek,
which I'm reading now.
That takes forever.
So thank you.
We'll see you next time.